I've had a fight break out while I was
on the story so I'm on stage in Ventura
I don't know where I just heard somebody
yell out that's my mama and then I'll
[ __ ] these two dudes are squared up I
hear him yell better which means [ __ ]
in Spanish and he starts choking this
lady my homie Jose sees that and he just
sees them dude choking a lady and he
sucks that dude I'm on stage like what
the [ __ ] is going on good left hook he
turns into Joe Rogan I was just like
shocked like does the show continue
little by little they Usher the people
out the cops come or whatever we find
out the lady was cheating on her husband
with that dude she was with at the show
the guy knew came with his daughter she
yelled out that's my mama husband cracks
cheater dude they start scoring up
that's what went down the husband was
choking his wife she was cheesy she was
cheating but like you can't choke your
wife
I got them to all sit down started just
kind of making fun of the whole
situation and then the show was great
like I'm really glad those fools got
down because like I was sucking ass and
everyone's like yeah you were sucking
ass and now we're having a good time